la décision est irrévocable et 68
membres de l'équipe d'athlétisme de la
russie sont exclus des jeux de rio
s'était suspendu souvenez-vous depuis
les révélations sur le dopage érigée en
système en russie et leur appel a été
rejeté
raymond saint-pierre encore ce matin
près de moscou des athlètes russes
s'entraînait tout en sachant que leur
sort était en train de se décider à 3000
kilomètres de là à lausanne d'accord
avec toi tu dors secrétaire générale du
tribunal arbitral du sport a annoncé qu
on rejeter l'appel des soixante huit
athlètes russes expulsés des jeux par la
fédération internationale d'athlétisme
pour cause de dopage d'état par la
russie
chez ces sportifs c'était la
consternation criaient à l'injustice
je me suis d'abord dit ça ne peut pas
être vrai ce n'est pas possible dit
maria kitchen à spécialiste du saut en
hauteur le monde est devenu fou
le ministre des sports russe vitaly
mutko parlait de décisions subjectives à
connotation politique sans fondement
juridique
il ajoutait seminelli chez cette
décision viole les droits des sportifs
propres et honnêtes et crée le précédent
de la responsabilité collective
les autorités russes prétendent que ce
scandale n'implique que des individus
qu'il n'y a pas eu de dopage d'état donc
qu'on doit pas punir tous les athlètes
dans les rues de moscou c'était
l'indignation
mon chef est il que ces athlètes ne
pourront aller à rio diane dre vélo'v
c'est dégoûtant c'est un complot chine
pixels c'est très triste dit ce fait
l'anah c'est une mauvaise décision nous
allons toujours être gagnant plusieurs
ici espère que le comité national
olympique fera preuve de plus de
magnanimité quand il se penchera
dimanche sur le sort de toute la
délégation russe pour les jeux de rio
387 athlètes en tout le cio attendait la
décision du tribunal arbitral du sport
avant de trancher
le temps presse il reste deux semaines
avant les jeux de rio
et si raymond st-pierre radio canada à
moscou